hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast using genome wide
sequencing to identify gene gene
interaction presented by dr. Christopher
Amos associate director of population
scientists professor of community and
family medicine at the gzl School of
Medicine
Norris cotton Cancer Center Dartmouth
College I am Alexis Carlson laberd's and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
laberd's lappers is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before I begin I would like
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me and welcome you
dr. Christopher Amos I will now turn the
presentation over to him thank you for
the introduction it's a great pleasure
to be presenting to you today so I'm
slightly change the title although I
will be covering the topics that were
discussed so the title is toward
precision medicine for cancer prevention
and early detection so what is precision
medicine and why do we use this term
since clinicians are always trying to
match their patient characteristics to
the most relevant treatment basically
you know we're under
a revolution in genomics and other
high-throughput profiling methods that's
because the technologies have evolved
very rapidly and the costs for
completely querying
a person's genome and attributes of the
disease have fallen precipitously making
it possible for us to characterize
what's happening in a disease us very
well and that's allowing us to provide
stunning improvements in some cases to
treatment and so we're going to talk
about how those changes can impact our
understanding of early stages in cancer
development and so with precision
medicine we can evaluate individual
specific mutations or polymorphisms and
changes that are occurring in expression
of RNA and so better tailor the disease
to the specific characteristics of the
of what's happening with it so in this
slide we're showing a diagram of the
general view of cancer development in
which there are early changes that occur
in the tumor and subsequently additional
mutations can occur and those lead to
heterogeneity in that in the tumor and
may adversely affect its behavior making
it harder to treat in many cases because
there are different branches of the
cancer different components of it that
may respond differently to treatment
however in many cases those early stages
may determine a treatment option and in
particular germline changes are
relatively common there's a recent
several recent studies coming out of for
instance sloan-kettering showing between
15 and 20
% of patients that have been routinely
screened for cancer having a germline
variant and in the state this is showing
you results from the TCGA for colon
cancer and they're showing that colon
cancers show a diversity of spectra with
respect to their the prevalence of
mutations that occur there is a set of
mutations with very high mutation load
these are individuals have often
germline mutations in one of the the DNA
mismatch repair genes would that make
them more susceptible to developing many
many more mutations and on this next
slide we're showing you results of a
study a landmark study that showed that
those patients overall colon cancer did
not respond to Pember liz' map which is
a pd-1 inhibitor it's also known as kate
ruta in the US so overall colon cancer
patients didn't respond much better than
on the treatment than was expected but
it turned out that if you had a mismatch
repair deficient tumor there was an
excellent response whereas if you were
not carrying a mismatch repair defect
there was no improvement so this is
showing that a germline variants can
have a profound impact on response to
therapy and this kind of finding extends
to several other kinds of cancers for
instance if you have an inherited
mutation in BRCA 1 or 2 and you have
ovarian cancer you respond much better
to apartment hibbott or and so that
those kinds of germline variants are
determining the way in which treatment
should be applied so the rest of
unless Li work on lung cancer so the
rest of my talk is talking about how
best to understand early stages of lung
cancer and the reason that that's
interesting yes
first of all lung cancer is often you
know associated with a bad outcome and
that's because most cases are detected
at a late stage we do know a lot about
etiology of lung cancer something like
85% of the attributable risk for
developing lung cancer comes from
cigarette smoking and there are other
occupational exposures that can increase
risk but also we know that the genetic
milieu may support or protect from
getting lung cancer so you know early
stage lung cancer has a much better
prognosis than late stage cancer
especially true from lung cancer and
many others so one of the more recent
findings was that the this large trial
the National lung screening trial showed
20% reduction in lung cancer among those
individuals who had low-dose spiral CT
and the mortality from mortality was 7%
lower so this is a relatively unusual
case in which screening and early
detection actually reduced overall
mortality not just to cause specific
component and also there is a dramatic
stage shift so that more cases were
detected earlier at earlier stages so
that means that we will be detecting
more early stage lung cancer as as the
screening it becomes more prevalent the
problem is the cost is quite dramatic
and the estimates are that not the cost
to Medicare
the 1.3 to two billion dollars a year so
right now screening is restricted to
individuals who have extensive history
of smoking and in some cases family
history can enter into the screen
screening guidelines but this does leave
quite a large population that are at
risk for getting lung cancer not being
screened so it's it's nice to have this
option but it's somewhat incomplete and
expensive we did alas I mentioned we do
know that smoking is a major driver for
lung cancer
this slide is showing what happens among
those people who keep smoking
so risk keeps accumulating if you quit
smoking risk levels off at the point at
which you have quit it but it still
increases sort of paralleling the rate
of increase associated with age so it's
not like cardiovascular disease where
risk goes back to normal and it always
your risk always stays elevated but it
just parallels where it was at the point
at which you quit so another kind of
comment here in terms of behavior you
know we know smoking is bad you know it
increases risk unfortunately with
cigarettes available we we have a new
sort of population of teenagers who are
becoming dependent on nicotine and
there's quite a bit of crossover between
these cigarettes and in cigarettes so
there's a slow population at risk and
also the US and other countries
smoking continues to be a problem so in
in lung cancer control
you know we'd like to minimize risk so
to do that
understanding how genetic and
environmental factors jointly influenced
I cancer risk is important and tobacco
smoke has many constituents so genetic
studies may provide some insights into
the mechanisms by which smoking behavior
is maintained and also potentially how
those harmful components in cigarettes
are influencing risk also we can use
genetic information to shed light on
other factors host specific factors that
influence cancer risk so I'll get to
that at the end and then we made to
identify subsets of people who benefit
the most and potentially some people
that would appear to be at higher risk
who won't benefit as much so in in the
background continuing there are some
high risk syndromes that predispose for
greatly elevated risks so people with an
inherited mutation of retinoblastoma
have about a 15 fold higher risk of
getting small cell lung cancer and we
know that small cell lung cancers often
have retinoblastoma mutations so those
two are tightly connected people with
p53 mutations they're quite uncommon but
their risks for getting lung cancer are
extremely high and they increase if they
have if they smoke and then there is a
homozygous mutation of EGFR which is
rare that is associated with lung cancer
groups and modeling in families and I
don't and showed that there's evidence
that in families there's a dominant a
genetic factor that can be inherited so
this is a slide just showing you if you
have an inherited p53 mutation that's
called leaf Remini syndrome and it's
characterized by high risks for getting
breast cancer and women
and multiple other cancers like leukemia
and sarcoma
but shown here in the circles are cases
of lung cancer also had neck cancers
occur so we did a study in earlier this
in the 2003 that showed what the high
risk of getting lung cancer is among the
carriers of p53 mutations so as I
mentioned earlier dense for a dominant
inheritance of susceptibility for
developing lung cancer and so in order
to identify those genetic factors we
organized a consortium that collects
samples from multiple sites to to in
order to identify those strongly acting
genetic factors the problem with
studying lung cancer in in this kind of
family design is that as I mentioned
earlier it's often lethal fairly quickly
and so it can be quite difficult to get
samples from multiple relatives you can
you can get the sample from the index
case at the time when that person is
diagnosed with lung cancer but trying to
collect data from the relatives is more
challenging one way to do that is to
collect samples from other tissues that
have been collected since
tonsillectomies or if they had lymph
nodes resected at the time of a surgery
another way to do that is to reconstruct
the genotypes of affected people from
the offspring so if you have one parent
let's say the person without lung cancer
that was married to the to the case and
children then you can reconstruct the
genotype of that of that parent and if
you
multiple relatives and you're missing
some you can still reconstruct with a
high probability so this requires you
know sort of an extensive network to
manage the collection the the genotyping
and the organization of data but we've
been doing that and so this is showing
you a kind of pedigree so looking at
pedigrees you know the squares are males
and circles are females and the affected
people are shaded kind of structure you
see lots of lung cancers and some head
and neck cancers and we really didn't
see other cancers showing up excessively
so it's really just a lung and having
that kind of like cancer structure so
when we analyze these data we found a
region on chromosome 6q that was
supporting evidence for a genetic factor
that evidence is measured by something
we called a lot score and lot scores
over three are considered very strong
evidence in this diagram where we're
showing that the evidence for an effect
is really restricted to those families
that have three or more affected persons
in the pedigree and really it's the four
or more in a pedigree that is driving
the evidence so the problem of the
Linksys is it does identify regions but
they can be quite broad so trying to
identify the specific genetic factor
that is driving this evidence for a
genetic susceptibility as is challenging
but we did identify a a variant that's
increased that's associated with the
increased risk in in some families so
the way we did that is we selected a
family and we evaluated
the individual and the family that had
lung cancer and we compared those cases
to other individuals who didn't have
lung cancer and by doing that
comparing the the cases from sequencing
with lung cancer to the k2 the controls
the relatives that didn't have cancer we
were able to and looking in that region
we're able to identify a few variants
that were that were Co inherited with
the disease and not with the unaffected
people and in particular there's a
variant of the park and park - that was
strongly associated you know this slide
is just showing you this variant isn't a
ring finger domain and it has a
functional impact so it's a pretty
strong candidate and it was found in
several other families so at least
explains some of the variability but
probably not all of the risk associated
with this region so we're continuing to
do the studies on high-risk families and
the advantage of families for this kind
of study is that we again can multiple
effective individuals in the family and
compared them to controls in the family
the best kind of control would be
someone who marries into the family and
not someone who's an offspring who could
be at risk but anyway they the other
individuals in the family are good they
match the cases in terms of the
environmental factors and probably
ethnic factors to a large degree and so
that those make it easier to sort out
like what a causal variant is in a
family if you're just sequencing random
individuals there's a tremendous amount
of information that you obtain
something if you do a whole genome
sequencing you'll end up with about
three million variants per person and
without some strong way of filtering
that information on becomes challenging
to assign causality to the variants that
you identify that this kind of analysis
can be done if you have large
populations of cases and controls
another caveat with that kind of design
is that you need to be sure that the
control sequencing and the case
sequencing is done in the same way
sometimes people choose cases and
sequence them and families and then
compare the sequences to something on
control they might get off the internet
the problem with that is if the
sequencing is done in a different manner
you'll get different variants being
identified and so while it's not always
necessary to have the controls
match perfectly to cases in terms of
their you know exposures I mean that is
the best definitely the most important
thing is to make sure that the
sequencing process is the same between
the case and control groups so on this
slide we're showing you sort of the
range of variation that exists in
population so what I have been talking
about until now was high risk families
in those cases we we have multiple
relatives affected with a cancer or some
disease and we can use occurrence of the
disease in the family to help us
identify the variant but that requires
that there's a high penetrance there's a
high probability that a person will get
affected given that they have a mutation
that predisposes to the disease those
kinds of high risk
variants are generally not very common
in the population because they're
selected against on the other hand there
have been many studies trying to
identify low risk variants that are
quite common these can have a
substantial impact at a population level
there are many many of these on for each
individual they they don't have much
effect but when their aggregate it they
can identify some individuals that have
high risk because they have multiple
variants on they're also very useful for
understanding the biology of of the
disease development so they do play an
important role in the middle there's a
sort of medium effect you know and
relatively uncommon those those are
actually quite hard to identify and that
kind of design would be select cases
with lots of relatives and trying to
sequence the case cases rather than
trying to collect the whole family that
that because in that case you need
relatively large sample sizes and the
families are going to be less
informative but so for this talk I'm I'm
switching to the sort of low effect
common variants for the rest of of what
I'll be talking about so in that case
what we do is a kind of case control
study so we just collect a bunch of
cases usually unrelated to anyone else
and then we collect controls people that
don't have the disease that had a
similar exposure pattern we often
require that they're from the same
ethnic population the reason we do that
is because different ethnic groups have
different alleles and if we don't
control in some way for ethnicity then
that becomes a confounder and we may
end up identifying lots of variants that
identify the ethnicity if the case and
control populations vary a little bit on
with respect to what their ethnic
background is so we we either have to
control for ethnicity and the analysis
or restrict to more homogeneous ethnic
populations and then if we want to
combine the data then we would do the
analyses within ethnicity and then do a
comparative analysis or a meta-analysis
across ethnicities so one one thing
about these kinds of studies as as I
mentioned the variants that we're see
who identify are common so that's a good
thing but they tend to have low effect
sizes and therefore we have to have very
large sample sizes to collect enough
individuals to be able to detect those
low effect sizes and so this is a study
that we've been involved in we at this
point when the slide was made we had
about 20,000 cases and about 30,000
controls and the analysis showed a very
striking association with a region on
chromosome 15 that contains nicotinic
acetylcholine receptor variants at the
time when these that were identified
they were kind of the ugly ducklings of
nicotinic acetylcholine receptors
because they're expressed at relatively
low levels in the brain and breast at
relatively higher levels in other
tissues so they weren't really the
receptors that were being studied by
most neuroscientists and more of
interests would be like CH RNA for and
CH RNA 7
but anyway we identified these variants
and so then the hunt was on to try and
figure out what they're doing and at the
same time the same region was being
identified as playing the most important
role for a tobacco smoke use again that
was surprising mechanisms weren't really
known for how those receptors would be
playing a role in tobacco so our
resource was able to show that these
there's there's a couple variants that
are very important and play a big role
one of them has been called mr. big by
Laura by root srs one six nine six nine
nine this is a variant that affects
signal transduction through CHR na v and
it was found to play a role in a number
of cigarettes smoked per day and it has
a very important role in smoking
cessation it seems people with this
variant have more of an impact event act
when they try to try to quit well then
there's another variant in the region
that affects expression of CHR na v so
the two variants Co occur on chromosomes
and when they do that they form a
haplotype that is a higher risk appetite
for higher amounts of smoking and more
difficulty in quit quitting
so Laura's group this is work by lesion
chin we're finding that when you have so
they took data from several existing
studies that compare the ability of
individuals to quit smoking if they had
either placebo treatment or they got a
pharmacological intervention they could
either get high B pro pro foo we
appropriate or varenicline
if they had if they had the high risk
appetites if they had two copies of
those the the high risk genetic factors
then the impact of treatment was
dramatically better response on the
other hand if they didn't have the
variants
then there was no impact of
pharmacological intervention so that
this was results from several different
trials but they were post-hoc analyses
and therefore the their group along with
Karin Luhrmann's group and in
Philadelphia are involved in trials to
understand if allocating patients based
on their genotypes will improve their
the ability to quit more effectively
that the implication from this study is
that you should probably allocate people
to to treatment according to their
genotypes because if they if they don't
have the risk genotypes then they won't
benefit from from this kind of
pharmacological intervention so we also
have now more recently designed a very
large study and what we did is we
brought together all the groups studying
common cancers and designed an array
that has about 500,000 markers that pass
all the quality control steps and that
includes a a set of markers that are
like road maps across the whole genome
to identify variability as well as
targets so we have pharmacogenetic
components and we also have some regions
that we were particularly interested in
and also variants that will inform about
risk factors like BMI
a chat menarche and so these were all
put onto this array and because we work
together we are able to reduce the cost
of the array to about $40 per person
that was analyzed and then the array was
configured it could be changed if other
groups wanted to join in and they would
get the 600,000 bead types but that
turns into about 500,000 genotypes
anyway they all other groups could join
in and you know about probably 500
thousand or so people have been
genotyped on these arrays and this just
shows you the different consortium that
formed the array in the beginning and
those acronyms are for the different
groups like line and colon and so forth
and so as I mentioned earlier in order
to make an analysis that is free from
confounding by ethnicity you have to
estimate the ethnic background and that
becomes very challenging with such a
huge study we developed a method that
will that's effective to apply across a
large study and what it does is it uses
the fact that in this figure you can see
on the lower right hand side those are
the genotypes projected onto principal
components of the of the European
descent individuals on the left-hand
side we have African descent and on the
top of the triangle or Asian descent
population so what we do is we take each
individual and project them to the
nearest position on the triangle or if
they're in the center to them you know
they're different positions on that
triangle and so by doing that we can
estimate the ethnic background of you
now typically for a European
only kind of analysis you would restrict
to individuals who are estimated to be
bad about 80% European for
african-american and Asians the sort of
profiles may vary a little bit but but
that's the way that we typically do the
analysis to try and restrict to to
better more homogeneous subsets so that
we don't get compounded by ethnic
background and so this shows you some
results for lung cancer when we apply
that array to European only populations
and basically the take-home from this
slide is that adenocarcinoma and
squamous carcinomas look very very
different in terms of their genetic
profiles there is similarity on that
chromosome 15 nicotinic acetylcholine
receptor region but otherwise also some
similarity on chromosome 5 where the
aged tert it's a gene that relates to
telomere function otherwise they look
quite different and in that study was
published in Nature Genetics in 2017 we
went further to try to understand some
of the new variants that we identified
the way we did that is we we connected
on the let me see on the x-axis we're
showing you the results from eqtl TTL
analyses so what in a region so we we
picked our our most associated snip and
then we looked in about a 200 kilobases
region around that snip and we've data
from gtex which is a a resource sum in
which people have contributed samples
and there is array data like genotype
array data and also expression array
data so for each
snip in a region you can see how much of
the variability in that snip is in that
in that expression profile is being
explained by this snip and you can also
on the y-axis we're showing a z-score
for association of the snip with lung
cancer risk by plotting these two things
against each other we can find that in
some of these regions the snips the most
significantly associated with lung
cancer snips are also very strongly a so
expression so for these four different
regions we're finding that the snip that
we identified is affecting most likely
affecting lung cancer risk by affecting
the expression levels so that that
actually makes the hunt for the for how
the mechanism for how the snips
affecting disease easier in these cases
there are many other ways in which snips
can affect or can be tagging their
variation that affects a disease and
often that's by very subtle impacts on
on the expression pattern so sometimes
it's quite difficult but in these cases
I think it's going to be easier
so for lung cancer why some people are
protected so we know we do and we know
people that have smoked a lot for years
and they don't get lung cancer so why is
that turns out that's not a very easy
question to answer all interaction
studies need much larger sample sizes
and that was a rationale for doing this
study was to assemble enough people that
we could do gene environment studies and
so we recently published a paper where
we did a rather intricate analysis in
which we start
with a case only approach in which we
compare the genotypes of cases that
according to smoking behavior and so
that allows for an interaction analysis
which is more powerful it turns out that
a case controlled as the problem with
the case only analysis is it's also
sensitive to any kind of substructure or
ethnic substructure in particular in
your population so we followed that up
with a case control design which is not
since and not as not as sensitive to
that and then we did replication and by
doing that we're and this is sort of
showing this statistical analysis so
first we have a case only design then we
have a case control with an interaction
component by doing that we found three
different regions and this is just
showing you the regional plots of the
Association of the snips with the
interaction term and in this kind of
complicated slide I'm showing you that
actually these interactions are ones in
which there's a protective effect so in
these cases having both smoking and that
genetic factor combined turn out to be
less severe of an effect then you would
predict from having either smoking or
the genotype so this is ends up finding
those some of those protective factors I
think further work would be helpful we
use of extremely conservative approach
so we're quite confident these are real
but we could also do more with a by not
being so restrictive in the analysis so
now we turn to other questions like how
can we approve lung cancer detection so
we know like epidemiological models
do actually pretty well they can predict
up to 25 some cases up to 80 percent of
the risk by allowing for sort of
polynomial on effects of smoking on on
risk genetic markers can improve the
risk by 4 to 5% but what about other
factors like BMI telomere length and can
we identify some other biomarkers that
that would improve their risk prediction
so that we can even further restrict the
analyses the screening behaviors to
those that would benefit the most
so one ongoing question in lung cancer
research is whether BMI is a risk factor
so if you just select cases of lung
cancer and study them you'll find that
they have lower BMI than the general
population and but that could be
problematic we know that if they're sick
before like if you know it takes several
years at least to develop a clinically
apparent case of lung cancer and during
that time the patients may be losing
weight due to the presence of the cancer
also if they smoke they're more likely
to eat less smoking as a bit of an
appetite suppressant so there's also
some association that high BMI increases
lung cancer risk among non-smokers so
it's kind of not the best when you have
BMI associated with increased risk in
non-smokers and decreased risk in in the
smoker so I mean this is just showing
you like if Isis naively you will find
that that lower BMI is a risk factor
higher BMI is protective for for lung
cancer when you do the analysis
now usually if you try to do a
prospective study so you collect BMI
several years before the cancer becomes
apparent there's less of an effect but
still lower BMI is somewhat of a risk
factor so there is a technique called
Mendelian randomization and the idea
here is that you use it the genetic
factors to exclude the effects that may
occur due to confounding so in this case
smoking is a confounder for the effect
of BMI on on the serve or reverse
causality and in that case reverse
causality is when the the presence of
lung cancer is affecting affecting BMI
so what's done is you first regressed
the genotypes on the phenotypes so
that's G 2 P and you get an estimate of
the relationship between in this case
BMI and genetic factors and you also
assess the risk associated in attacks
and the disease outcome and so then by
forming the ratio of those two
regressions so the regression of the
disease on the genotype and the
regression of the disease on the
phenotype then you can get an estimate
of the effect of the phenotype the BMI
on the disease outcome so in the as an
example we can look at body mass index
so the observational estimate is that
having a higher BMI is protective for
getting lung cancer and then in this
earlier study what was found with 28
snips is predicting the
the BMI that actually it looks like BMI
might be become a bit of a risk factor
so this kind of analysis has been
recently updated so in this analysis
they first checked that they had a good
set of genetic predictors for BMI and
they show in the top part of this figure
that in both cases and controls on the
set of snips they're using to predict
BMI really do work and they also show
that those same genetic factors don't
predict smoking behavior so that means
that you know you're not getting can
some kind of confounding from the snip
predictors on smoking so that was a very
good quality step that they did then
when they applied this analysis to to
that data that I showed earlier from
from our consortium they see some
evidence for an effect of BMI on risk
for lung cancer but actually further
analysis shows that this association is
restricted just to those patients that
develop squamous or small cell cancer
and for adenocarcinoma might be a little
bit protective so so this is a where
this kind of association can improve our
ability to estimate the effect of a a
host specific factor in this case BMI on
lung cancer risk and so again it's
suggesting that increased BMI is
actually the risk factor for getting
lung cancer so another question you
might ask what about telomeres so
telomere length shortens with age
cancers can develop among individuals
with with short telomeres we do know
that exists and there were several
papers that showed an association of
shorter telomeres with increased risk
for cancer but that could be due to bias
associate with sampling cases and
controls at different times or there
might be some kind of reverse causality
and so that the genetic versus
observational study so by the way those
associations of telomere length with
with cancer risk were quite
heterogeneous so a lot there were some
that showed an association of short
telomeres with increased link length I
think most of them were going the other
way with longer telomeres being bad and
so if you look at sort of meta analyses
and versus this Mendelian randomization
you see that in this case they actually
are quite are fairly similar with maybe
the genetic Mendelian randomization
estimate being a little bit worse that
telomere longer telomeres are worse than
what we got from meta-analysis and
actually turns out you can because those
estimations that I showed in the
beginning for Mendelian randomization
can be so you can do the analysis of the
genetic factors on the phenotype in one
population and the genetic factors on
the disease outcome and the other
population and then you can just put the
two estimators together and so you can
quickly scan through lots of possible
associations between diseases and and
certain intermediate phenotypes or you
can do lots of intermediate phenotypes
and a specific disease and in this slide
what's being done is comparing on
telomere length versus lots of different
diseases and lung cancer turns out to be
the most significantly associated
outcome for telomere length and so it's
definitely bad it's also bad for lots of
other does cuts are especially bad for
glioma and on
the other hand you know for some lung
diseases like interstitial lung disease
or idiopathic pulmonary fibrosis having
short telomeres is a risk factor I think
the take-home message from this slide is
despite what you might see on TV don't
try to make your telomeres longer
because while it might protect you from
cardiovascular disease it may increase
your risk for cancer quite dramatically
so this is like I was saying earlier you
can apply the same kind of approach to
lots of different phenotypes for a
specific disease and when you do that
for lung cancer you find as you should
that smoking is the most important
factor but also turns out biting maybe
off is also a risk factor so having high
vitamin b12 this is bad we don't really
know why and this preliminary result has
been confirmed now in a paper that I
think just is coming out in JAMA
oncology so I'm gonna close this pretty
soon there's a pretty complicated study
that was recently published doing the
same kind of analysis with the
metabolites so they did a metabolite
and they looked at lots of snips and
connected that to lung cancer when they
do that they find arachidonic acid
metabolite being very very strongly
associated with with lung cancer risks
so that that's sort of allowing us to
screen through lots of new sort of
phenotypes that might be associated with
lung cancer some older studies so
bilirubin has been associated with
protection from lung cancer and there's
a for example per surfactant protein B
is also a fairly robust biomarker for
the development of lung cancer I did
want to just man
in this truly massive study that was
done it was really designed to look I
think for cardiovascular disease and
bilirubin but um they studied about five
hundred thousand people and what they
found so these are people with normal
ranges of bilirubin but just kind of
varies and so there is a gel Barre
syndrome as an example where people are
born with a mutation in utt 1a1
influences their B to metabolize
bilirubin and so when their so that's
when they're when they're very young
they have to be sort of treated for that
but anyway there's lots of variability
in the population it turns out that that
higher bilirubin is protective from lung
cancer and COPD and also people with
shell Barre syndrome are protected
actually from pulmonary diseases so
those things go together so I just want
to thank all the people I collaborate
with this is only a small subset of them
but we work very well in teams we have
mechanisms for sharing our data and we
we always welcome that within the
constraints that we try to you know make
the analyses as consistent among groups
so there's not too much overlap and so
some are summarizing there are high risk
mutations in retinoblastoma p53 some
very rare mutations in EGFR and then we
have a region on 6q that is influencing
familial lung cancer so these are
uncommon but they can shed quite a lot
of insight into the etiology of lung
cancer there are nicotinic receptors
region on chromosome 15 and there's a
couple other nicotinic receptors now
that are
located also the H dirt region is
influencing a lung cancer risk and those
are in common across the different
cancers but if you look at adeno
carcinoma and squamous carcinoma they
they look almost completely distinct as
if they're they're really not related in
terms of their basic ideology so I
didn't talk about this too much but the
squamous carcinomas have often mutations
in homologous recombination repair
including a mutation CA to rad52
check - and HMS h5 and also the HLA
region the DNA repair genes seem to be
more relevant for adenocarcinoma we said
that we found that long telomere length
increases lung cancer risk and BMI also
appears to contribute especially the
squamous and small cell carcinoma
genetic information is providing a great
number of new insights into the etiology
of lung cancer and other common cancers
and seems to be particularly useful for
identifying host factors that have a
genetic influence usually you know when
we do Mendelian randomization it's quite
informative but we also like to follow
that up with more direct analysis of
trying to show that the factor studying
is directly related to the disease
outcome so we would typically you know
do Meneely and randomization as a way of
scanning through markers and then do
additional studies but but I think this
method is turning out to be quite
informative so you know as we go forward
in time a combination of genetic
epidemiological and biomarker panels
will be needed for risk stratification
and one other comment here is that
fortunately most of our studies have
been done on European descent
there are studies in Asians and Asian
descent and truly underrepresented at
this time our populations of African
Americans and Hispanics and that partly
reflects the difficulty in collecting
stance populations they they tend to be
less common at every site so in order to
do the the studies you have to get
multiple investigators to participate
and and also in some cases reluctance
from the affected individuals to
participate in some studies so you know
we need to make efforts to improve the
the participation and others in other
populations on African descent
populations are a particular interest
for lung cancer or prostate cancer and
some other cancers that are more common
in those groups and they're also useful
for understanding the genetics because
they have a more diverse genetic
background they and are you know many
different groups and so they are more
informative it's just been a limitation
of a lot of these studies up till now so
thank you very much for listening and
I'm happy to take comments I'm a little
sorry that I only talk about lung cancer
but it's something that I am very
interested in studying so thanks a lot
thank you dr. Amos for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left a
press of your presence
Station window type your question into
the box that appears on the screen and
click the send button well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for so let's get started dr. Amos our
first question is what kind of design
would be best for identifying a common
variant with a lower level of effect on
disease risk well for that kind of
design we would usually use a case
control design and the reason we do that
is because it's fairly easy to collect
cases with the disease and controls
without the disease and and then the
costs of the analysis are also not so
high these days because we can usually
use an array based technology to
identify those genotypes that are
associated with the case status and then
we have known linkage disequilibrium
patterns those are associations among
alleles that allow us to infer most of
the variability across the entire
genotype and Geno our next question is
why could testing for the effects of BMI
on lung cancer risk lead to an erroneous
finding if incident lung cancer cases
and controls were studied so that again
I explain the reason for that is because
cases may have been sick before they
came to attention and lost weight
because of that or they if they smoke a
lot then they tend to be thinner and it
looks like we have time for one more
question why our consortium needed to
identify high risk variants
influence influencing lethal diseases
but how can we use family data to
overcome limitations in accessing enough
disease affected individuals so we need
consortium because those families that
are informative are harder to find
and so you need to be able to share the
samples and the data among the different
places that can collect that kind of
information and infer the genotypes from
the offspring and the individuals who
married into the family so that does
will allow us to infer the genotypes of
any individuals who were diseased or and
also died before you could collect
samples from them I would like to once
again thank dr. Amos for his
presentation I would also like to thank
laberd's for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through August of 2018 you will receive
an email from laberd's letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye